well the reason I wrote the no
rule is a pretty simple reason is that I
was just sick of being in places where
there were and and working and
talking with executives who were about
to mean and demeaned and de-energized
and it seemed like sort of a simple idea
to build an organization that had the no
rule it's actually kind of funny
because the reason that I use the word
rather than perhaps cleaner variations
like bully or jerk or something is they
don't quite capture the emotional
response that we get when somebody is
nasty to us or even when I'm like bad I
don't say to myself you jerk I say to
myself you so it's it captures
the emotional part and the way I would
define it would be somebody who is an
somebody who consistently leaves
others feeling demeaned and de-energized
especially people have less power the
response to the book has been generally
positive but there have been two
interesting sort of opposing reactions
that I'm quite fascinated by one is that
a lot of people like the chapter that
talks about how to build an free
organization and sort of the poster boy
for that job that chapter is one of your
alums Lara's dalgaard and I'm so Larson
started a company about six or seven
years ago called success factors and
it's it's a very successful startup
they're a human resource management
software firm they're the largest
software firm over 30 million people
they've grown from a hundred people to
four hundred people in the last year so
and among other things they have every
employee who joined the organization
sign a statement saying that they won't
be an
there's other they call the rules of
engagement there's other ones but the
last one is that I won't be an
so that one it's sort of fascinating and
then the other one is the chapter which
unfortunately my friend Jeff Pfeffer
likes the best which is the chapter that
makes the argument about the virtues of
so I talked about vertically
actually about Steve Jobs and how
independently of or maybe because he's
an he's been so successful
and I wrote that with some hesitation
and I emphasized in the end of that
chapter that if you're successful and
you're an you're still an
and I don't want to be around
you but my colleague Jeff Pfeffer he
focuses on the successful part and
doesn't seem to think that being an
is quite so bad one of the
questions that I keep getting asked over
and over again is to put it simply our
born or are they made and
there's two main factors that I think
lead to people turning to
situational factors and certainly people
might be predisposed but I think the
situations are especially powerful one
is the the notion that all emotions
including being a jerk is something that
you catch from other people so I talked
about the notion in the book that that
when people join organizations where
there's a bunch of jerks around they
catch what I call poisoning the
second one and this relates to a
professor Deborah Brent Feld's research
who's a professor at the Business School
that she's done an extensive amount of
research about the notion that the way I
would put it she would put it more
politely that that putting people in a
position of power sort of instantly and
efficiently turns them into insensitive
jerks or and what she finds
across a whole series of studies is that
when you take people and just randomly
assign them into position and more power
over others there's sort of three things
that happen one is they start getting
less sensitive to the needs of other
people the second thing that happens is
they start becoming more focused on
satisfying their own needs and the third
thing is she calls this thing distant
disinhibition where people become less
inhibited about social norms and my
favorite little study that she did was
something about how the cookie crumbles
where she brought people plates of
cookies and if she just gave one person
a little more power than the other they
tended to take an extra cookie they
tended to eat with their mouths open and
create more crumbs and so if so this
notion that that being put in into power
really does turn you into a pig it's
kind of documented by this in other
studies so the question of what
reactions have surprised me the most
well two things have surprised me one is
how many media sources are letting me
get away with saying the dirty word
because and I'm getting some pushback I
admit but even I was interviewed a few
months ago by Ron Reagan who is
President Reagan Sonny as a talk-show in
Seattle this was a midday talk-show and
we used the word a hole which I which I
thought was even against FCC regulations
but we merrily did that and then the
other one which happened just yesterday
that surprised me the most is is I
thought that religious people will be
generally offended by the word and I'm
sure there are some who are who are
offended but I was interviewed by a
German magazine that's um that's pot
that's funded by the Episcopal Church in
Germany and supposedly has 1.5 million
readers and my interviewer he told me he
was doing the article because the no
rule was such a Christian idea
and uh and very consistent the golden
rule and I tried to be sort of shocked
even a little cynical but once I started
talking to him he made such a compelling
argument that if you actually read the
Bible it was very consistent with with
Christian values so so so that sort of
shocked me at the moment I'm trying to
actually resolve that is kind of amazing
but I guess it is quite consistent the
golden rule so that's probably the
single most surprising thing that's it's
happening me so far with the book um
well I I think that it's not only
arrogant but inaccurate to argue that
any single book will have a dramatic
effect on the workplace there actually
are as Jeff Pfeffer and I argue in our
last book there are a few new management
ideas there's been lots written about
about why that you should have bullies
and the like at the workplace but I I'm
hoping that it's part of a movement that
I'm starting to see both illegal and a
management movement to be less tolerant
of people who are demeaning and also to
glorify people who are demeaning who get
in positions of power less and and there
are some sort of weak hints that
corporate America is being a little less
tolerant of people who are effective but
our nasty jerks so I can the case of Bob
Nardelli who was just fired at Home
Depot and also Michael Eisner at Disney
at the very least it
years that one of the reasons that the
boards were less tolerant of their
performance problems was because of
their reputation for putting down others
and doing other sort of nasty sneaky
things so the question of whether I'm
planning any additional writing in this
topic is actually pretty funny I
continue to write about various stories
associated with on my blog and
I'm writing a number of articles
including the one I was just working on
this morning is for the McKinsey
quarterly which will be somewhat
censored but it's going to make the
argument for its read by Maclean's
McKinsey clients that should be
interesting but honestly I don't think I
have it in me to write another book on
the topic I think that I've given
everything I had to this one and I don't
think I'll be doing a sequel
you